Now, in order to limit the amount of contention
on the network when a lock is released, we're
going to do something that we often do in real
life. procrastination. So basically, the idea is the following.
Each processor is going to delay asking for the
lock, even though they observe that the lock is
released. Then I will immediately go and try to
get the lock. They're going to wait for a little bit
of time. It's sort of like what happens at rush
hour. If you find that the this traffic is too
much, you might decide that I don't want to get on
the highway right now. I'm going to delay a little bit
so that I don't have to spend as much time
on the highway. So that's sort of the same thing
that is being proposed here, and this is what is
called spinlocks with delay. Let's discuss two different delay alternatives.
In the first one, you're here. You found that you
did not get the lock and therefore, you're here locally
spinning in your cache, waiting for the lock to be
released. Normally what you would have done, when the lock
is released, is go back out, break out of this
loop and go back and check if you can get
the lock again. But what we're going to do is,
instead of doing that, when we break out of this loop,
meaning that the lock has been release, I'm
not going to immediately go and check to see
if I can get the lock. I'm doing to
delay myself by a certain amount of time. And
you notice that the delay is conditioned by what processor id I
have. So every processor is waiting for a different amount of
delay in order to contend for the lock. So since the delay
is being chosen differently for each processor, even though
all of them notice that the lock has been released
simultaneously, only one of them will go and check
it. And so we are sort of sequentializing the order
in which the processors that are waiting for the
lock are going to check whether the lock is available.
So that is one possible scheme for delaying. Now
the problem with this is it's a static delay, right?
So every processor has been preassigned a certain
amount of delay, which means that even if
the lock is available, I may not immediately
go and check because my delay may be very
high compared to some other processor. And that's
always an issue when you have static decision
making. What we can do is instead make
the decision dynamically, and what we're going to do is,
when we notice that we don't have the lock,
we're going to delay ourselves by a certain amount of
time before we try for the lock again. You
notice that if you're going to delay checking for whether
I have the lock or not. It's not super
critical that, that you spin locally or go to
memory. But in this example, I'm making it very
simple by saying that if you don't get the
lock, just delay a little bit before you try for
this lock again. And the idea here is this delay
is, is some small number to start with. But suppose
I go and check and I find it again to
be locked. Now, what I'm going to do is the
next time around, I'm going to increase the delay. That's
why it's called exponential backoff. So I'm increasing the delay,
doubling the amount of delay that I'm going to do.
So that the next time, if I don't find
the lock to be available, I delay by twice
the amount from the previous time. And this is
essentially saying that when the lock is not highly contented
for, I'm not going to delay myself too much. I'm
going to immediately go and get it. But on
the other hand, if I go back again and
again, and every time I go and check, I find
it is locked, I'm going to increase the amount of
delay. Because that's saying that lot of people are contending
for the lock at the same time. And therefore,
in order to make sure that we are being sensitive
to the contention that is there for the lock,
we increase the amount of delay that we're experiencing. Now
one nice thing about this simple algorithm that I've shown
you is that I'm not using the caches at all.
And, if the, if the processor happens to
be a non-cache coherent multi-processor, this algorithm will
still work. Because we're always using test and
set, and not using just loading from the memory.
Because if it is not a cache-coherent multiprocessor,
your private cache is now going to be coherent
with respect to memory. And so you have
to execute test and set. But you don't want to
do it all the time. And this delay makes sure that you can reduce the amount
of contention on the network. Generally speaking. If
there's a lot of contention, then static assignment
of delay may be better than the dynamic
exponential backoff. But in, in general any kind
of delay, any kind of procrastination, will help
a lock algorithm better than the naive spin lock
that we talked about.